blind la nota a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a me sono video sono file sono
stato starò perché a me non mi riposo un
po gli occhi che sto sempre registrare
ha fatto scalpore sta roba della leader
che ha fatto dei vestiti precisissimi
così sulla ma un viaggio per vedere se
riesco a infiltrarmi tra i ragazzi
inosservato avrà funzionato non lo so
scoprirete solo un grande vino mi
raccomando centra un bel commento
buona visione
ma doc è partita incredibile io e step
raga madonna fantastico ma da allora
ragazzi l'importante che cos'è
l'importante è riuscire a districarci
dalle varie tasche da fare perché
secondo me è un problema allora prova ad
andare da questa parte quattro come sono
ma lista andare di qua dove sei messi io
eccolo qua perfetto plant match perfetto
defoe e mi ha detto che le tasche c'è
l'ha detto a tutti quanti quindi l'ha
detto anche a me che le tasche stanno
finendo quindi era un modo per dirmi la
doppia dovremmo fare la doppia carica
mente non ho idea ragazzi perché devo
beccare qualcuno io io farei sempre la
roba di l'aics delle luci
no se c'è qualcuno in security cioè
nessun i security gli occhi non vediamo
se riesco a fare live
ok
chi ha dato accesso c'era cesca qua dove
march ce l'ha ma roma è morto mattino da
definire questi attrattiva retrocamera
entrato marcipedi dove era chi è che le
scatole di di ammazzare martina io no ma
sempre così ma io ero ragazzo è permesso
noi non ci deve mai il primo turno anche
parlare il povero fanciulla resta da
nessuno ballo più no non voglio parlare
di katia una carpe non ti regala niente
macché ma mamma perché mi sento affatto
velata a casa a caso molto bene raga e
il momento di fare la doppia io ma
comunque marcis compagni ma lo vedi
ma march scompare march scompare dalle
co bataille march scompare dal nulla c'è
valcic al e aac da un po march cia l'eac
scomparso nel nulla quasi come non sono
ragazzi peak lights and light sono già
fissate a posto
dov'è allora elettrica l'avevo appena
finito di fare fix lights e vedo degli
che uccide cesca ma cerca viva come
raffaele scusate sono babbo si era
confermo confermo perché entravo in quel
momento ero che so anch'io che bisogna
vedere 100 120 queste moto rollando io
lo sto già perché ho provato votiamo
casa questa partita gamma aspetta
l'altro chi è perché io non sono cioè vi
giuro qualche partita ma ragazzi ho
visto march scomparire otto volte
davanti a me pugile mola league
la leader sono sempre leader ogni giorno
è speso cercando di trovare l'impostore
ma se riesco a fare la sleep della
tessera sono un commesso della linea
molto più veloce più come solarità 724
due gol e si fa anche oxygen proprio
nome che si sanno giocare legano subito
trovata l'emergency non ce li facciamo
scappare
allora tanto i primi che muoiono moglie
da sempre in navigation ed è importante
che io vado in navigation a capire chi è
morto perché tanto qualcuno marzo sempre
alle ciance step per se stessi o bevi
cesca allora vorrei sapere che cosa
avete da dire prima che io parli allora
io posso dire che è stato uno fra lido
le baby cesco peter non è stato perché
io stavo nascosta nella vento
io ho visto uno schizzo di sangue
ragazzo se bevi cesca e non può essere
leader lezione dai priori
memori noi c'è stato pure io in quel
corridoio sole scalzata da sola o
medicis collidono mobilità da mi fido
delle h il suicidio nel caso questa non
è la pazzesco
ora che adesso cerchiamo ammazza perché
lo sa che sono io cioè io lei sa che io
so porco demonio cambio è all'emergency
per forza
fate storia store porco demonio che sono
le scale emergency fatelo nessuno lo fa
no ragazzi nel suo fare arte ok rancesco
dai baffi ma sono stato disconnesso
stavo nella mente e chi era la prima
partita prima l'altro era l'altro
politica e si chiama marcia madonna che
sfiga era ora non mi fate crollare bene
poi tra l'altro detto io vado sempre in
elettrica non vedo me morire nessuno poi
mi ricordo che stiate diciamo recente il
navigation po di navigation vedo sui due
numeri e dei ragazzi il mio
travestimento da lì dal man 3 sia stato
di vostro gradimento e vi ringrazio per
ha visto quindi schede al canale
ghiacciate quel tasto non mi piace che
trovate qui sotto che non è che serve
serve schiacciato e non ci vediamo come
sempre anno prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]